Transcription:
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonjour à toutes et à tous.
Aujourd’hui, j’avais envie
de vous parler de paradoxe.
Et je vais commencer par un des miens.
On vient de vous le dire,
la plupart du temps, dans ma vie,
je défends les animaux.
Mais en vrai,
je n’aime pas les animaux.
Depuis toute petite,
je ne suis pas à l’aise avec eux.
Quand j’ai dix ans,
Gaston arrive dans ma vie.
C’est un chien ;
il n’est pas câlin du tout ;
il veut juste manger,
dormir et se promener.
Ce n’est pas comme dans les films
ou les séries que je vois à la télévision
où on a des amitiés formidables
entre un chien et un enfant.
Alors, je n’aime pas les animaux,
mais je ne leur veux pas de mal non plus.
Ne me faites pas dire
ce que je n’ai pas dit !
Juste, je reste à une distance
très polie des animaux.
Lorsque j’ai 18 ans -  je suis au lycée -
je rencontre Sébastien.
Je tombe amoureuse.
Coup de bol, c'est réciproque.
Très rapidement,
il m’emmène dans sa famille.
J’y rencontre ses grands-parents.
Félix, qui est là-bas à l’extrémité,
était boucher.
Il est aussi, encore à l’époque
où je fais sa connaissance, maquignon,
c’est-à-dire qu’il achète et qu’il revend
des veaux aux éleveurs, aux boucheries.
Antonin, qui est tout à droite,
à ma droite, est éleveur laitier.
Avec son épouse, ils ont encore
une dizaine de vaches laitières,
un cochon dans un box de l’étable,
des poules et des canards
qui courent partout.
Ce sont des gens chaleureux :
coup de foudre, encore.
Le premier jour,
on boit du café, on mange des gâteaux.
Le soir tombe.
C’est l’heure de « fermer les poules »,
comme on dit là-bas.
Et c’est une poule qui le dit.
Elle est montée sur le rebord
de la fenêtre, elle toque au carreau.
On m’explique :
en fait, le grand-père doit aller
la chercher, la prendre dans ses bras,
la bercer, et aller la coucher
à son emplacement, dans le poulailler.
Je vais ainsi découvrir la vie à la ferme,
dans une ferme familiale.
Je ne vais pas vraiment m’intéresser
à la vie des vaches laitières.
Je ne vais pas rentrer les poules.
Par contre, j’aurai le grand honneur
de conduire le tracteur pendant les foins.
Je vais aussi tourner les saucisses,
parce que, je ne vous ai pas dit,
mais le grand-père, Antonin,
est aussi le saigneur du village -
« saigneur », a-i.
Il tue les cochons, y compris le sien,
pour en faire du lard, du jambon,
des saucisses, des saucissons.
Je ne verrai jamais la tuerie du cochon.
Sébastien, ça fait déjà quelques années
qu’il n’y va pas :
les cris du cochon qui hurle
au moment de sa mise à mort
ne le mettent pas du tout à l’aise ;
mais il continue à manger de la viande.
Il planque même du saucisson
sous son lit depuis qu’il est tout petit.
Et puis un jour, patatras !
Un paradoxe qu’on n’avait pas vu arriver
du tout nous arrive en pleine figure,
et ça se passe par l’intermédiaire
d’une bande dessinée.
Pourquoi celle-là ?
Pourquoi à ce moment-là ?
Aucune idée !
C’est la vie de Siddhartha,
premier Bouddha, qui est retracée
dans cette bande dessinée.
On le voit à un moment en pénitence,
à l’extérieur du monastère,
dans le froid glacial.
Deux moines passent
avec quelque chose de lourd sur le dos.
La couverture se soulève et dessous,
on voit un cochon mort.
Et notre brave moine de dire :
« Finalement, moi ça va,
à côté de ce qu’a vécu ce cochon-là. »
On ne se rappelle plus du tout
ce qu’on s’est dit juste après,
mais ça a été la décision la plus rapide
et la plus impactante de notre vie.
Nous avons décidé de ne plus manger
ni viande ni poisson
pour ne pas faire tuer d’animaux.
Alors, on va se lancer
dans une autre façon de cuisiner,
au départ hasardeuse, voire désastreuse.
On est en 1993.
Il n’y a pas Internet,
pas de sites comme Vegan Pratique
pour nous apprendre à faire à manger.
Nos familles, bienveillantes,
nous font des repas végétariens
quand on y va.
Mais il y a quand même quelque chose
qui nous taraude dans ce choix personnel.
Est-ce que c’est vraiment
un choix personnel ?
Est-ce que dans notre société,
il n’y a pas quelque chose qui cloche
dans notre façon de nous comporter
avec les animaux ?
Le personnel est politique,
surtout en cuisine.
Quelques années plus tard, on rencontre
d’autres énergumènes comme nous.
En fait, on va découvrir
un vrai mouvement,
philosophique, militant,
qui défend les animaux,
et qui remet en question
l’organisation même de notre société,
avec les êtres humains d’un côté,
les autres animaux de l’autre.
Je vais y retrouver Pythagore qui,
entre deux triangles rectangles,
philosophait, figurez-vous,
et remettait en question
le fait de faire tuer des animaux
pour les manger
alors qu’on n’en a pas besoin.
Bon, sachant tout ça,
on n’allait pas rester les bras ballants,
surtout qu’on a deux enfants.
Si pour nous, la démarche
a été purement intellectuelle,
eux n’ont jamais mangé de viande,
et ils n’arrivent pas à s’imaginer
comment nous, êtres humains, on fait
pour élever, tuer, découper en morceaux,
porter à notre bouche,
les cadavres d’autres animaux.
J’ai essayé de me figurer
ce que c’était, et je me dis,
c’est comme si on me proposait
de manger du chat ou des insectes :
juste, ça ne se fait pas.
De fil en aiguille, on crée
des collectifs, des groupes,
et une association : L214.
L214 tire son nom du code rural qui,
pour la première fois en 1976,
reconnaît que les animaux
sont des êtres sensibles.
Une équipe de TF1
s’intéresse à notre travail,
et je réussis à fixer deux rendez-vous
la même journée :
le premier, dans un élevage
de poules pondeuses -
50 000 poules pondeuses dans un bâtiment,
neuf étages de cages blindées de poules.
À l’époque, 80 % des poules
sont élevées en cage de batterie,
aujourd’hui, 47 % grâce à l’action
des citoyennes et citoyens, et des ONG.
Demain, avec l’engagement
qu’on a obtenu des supermarchés,
de l’hôtellerie restauration,
des fabricants, des producteurs,
on espère qu’à l’horizon 2025,
il n’y aura plus de poules en cage.
Le deuxième élevage qu'on visite,
c'est un élevage de cochons.
Le preneur de son de TF1 en ressort blême.
Pourtant, on n’a pas vu
la castration à vif ;
on n’a pas vu le meulage des dents ;
on n’a pas vu la coupe des queues ;
on n’a pas vu le claquage
des porcelets chétifs contre un mur,
ou contre le sol.
Mais il a vu ces truies
qui sont enfermées dans des cages,
sans pouvoir bouger,
juste se lever, se coucher,
et les petits qui tètent
à travers les barreaux :
95 % des cochons
sont élevés dans ces conditions-là.
La même année, Sébastien se fait
embaucher pendant trois semaines
chez Charal, à Metz.
Nos enfants sont encore petits
et pourtant ils se rappellent.
Ils se rappellent l’odeur
quand Sébastien rentrait,
l’odeur de chair, de sang,
d’excréments, d’urine, le tout mélangé.
Ils se rappellent aussi son épuisement :
épuisement psychologique,
épuisement physique.
Mauricio García-Pereira, qui est notre
lanceur d’alerte à l’abattoir de Limoges,
qui a montré l’abattage
des vaches gestantes,
qui a montré aussi
les fœtus de veaux jetés à la poubelle,
nous racontera la perte de l’estime de soi
quand on est ouvrier d’abattoir :
quatre fois plus de risques
d’accidents du travail.
Il nous racontera l’alcool, la drogue
pour tenir, et la cadence infernale.
Trois millions d’animaux sont tués
par jour en France, dans les abattoirs.
Si on ramenait ça sur un mois,
3 millions pendant un mois, c’est plus
que toute la population française
qui passe de vie à trépas
dans les abattoirs chaque mois.
Est-ce qu’au moins les éleveurs
sont heureux ?
Eh bien, rien n’est moins sûr.
Ceux qu’on a vus nous disaient
être mal à l’aise
quand les animaux partaient à l’abattoir.
Certains s’arrangeaient même
pour ne pas être là à ce moment-là.
Alexandre, éleveur laitier à la retraite,
m’a raconté en pleurant doucement
qu’il avait cherché, pendant toute
sa carrière, à connaître le moment
où il pouvait séparer le veau de sa mère,
pour que ce ne soit pas si terrible.
Il n’a pas trouvé.
Et puis, plus récemment,
cet éleveur de poulets, à Pihem.
Cet éleveur a un projet.
Aujourd’hui, il a un élevage, un bâtiment
avec 22 000 poulets à l’intérieur.
Il veut multiplier par cinq sa production.
Ce sont des poulets à croissance rapide,
des poulets qui grossissent
quatre fois plus vite qu’en 1950,
qui ont des problèmes de pattes,
des problèmes cardiaques et respiratoires.
Pour s’en sortir financièrement,
il doit multiplier sa production par cinq,
emprunter 1,4 million d’euros,
rembourser 10 000 euros
par mois pendant 12 ans.
Et avec ça, il espère récupérer un revenu
de 800 euros par mois pour lui
et 1 500 euros pour sa femme.
Le groupe qui lui fait faire
la connerie de sa vie
lui garantit des revenus pendant un an,
et pendant le reste du temps,
les onze autres années,
le moindre pépin, ce sera la banqueroute.
Une canicule, c'est le mur.
La hausse du prix des céréales,
c’est le mur.
Et donc, que faire ?
Pour l’instant, le préfet
n’a pas donné son accord.
On ne sait pas encore ce qui va se passer.
Alors, est-ce que ce sont
les seules conséquences
de nos modes de production
alimentaires et agricoles ?
Eh bien, pas seulement.
Vous avez certainement entendu parler
des 14,5 % d’émissions de gaz à effet
de serre, dus au secteur de l’élevage.
Saviez-vous que manger végétarien,
c’est en fait six fois plus efficace
pour réduire les gaz à effet de serre
que manger local ?
Saviez-vous que la surface
que vous utilisez
en tant que français moyen,
mangeur de viande,
est trois fois plus importante
que celle d’un végétalien ?
Et 65 % de la déforestation
de la forêt amazonienne
est due aux activités d’élevage.
D’un côté, les feed-lots avec des bovins,
de l’autre côté,
les céréales et les légumineuses
qu’on fait pousser
pour nourrir les animaux d’élevage.
Déforestation, élevage intensif,
c’est aussi une des causes
des zoonoses, c’est-à-dire
ces maladies qui sont transmissibles
des animaux aux êtres humains.
Serge Morand, chercheur au CNRS,
nous dit que les élevages intensifs
sont de véritables bombes sanitaires.
Avec tout ça, pourquoi
on ne change pas plus rapidement ?
Pourquoi, au moins,
on n’a pas éliminé l’élevage intensif ?
Parce qu’on baigne
dans une culture de l’élevage.
Et puis, il y a aussi notre cerveau.
Pendant des années -
je vous l’ai dit, le grand-père
de Sébastien était éleveur laitier,
l’autre prenait les veaux
et les vendait à l’abattoir -
je ne me suis pas rendu compte
du coût des produits laitiers.
Pourtant, je l'avais sous les yeux.
En fait, notre cerveau est formidable.
Il va nous aider à trouver des excuses,
de la plus sincère à la plus pitoyable.
Oh, les carottes !
Les carottes souffrent !
Moi, je n’ai jamais rencontré autant
de défenseurs des plantes et des légumes
que depuis que je suis végane.
Si vraiment le sort des légumes
et des plantes nous intéresse,
alors il faut consommer 100 % végétal,
puisqu’il faut
entre 3 et 10 kilos de végétaux
pour produire un kilo
de produits d’origine animale.
Les lions !
Les lions mangent les gazelles,
ce n’est pas une preuve ça ?
Mais l’organisation sociale des lions,
c’est aussi l’infanticide.
Est-ce qu’on va prendre
notre modèle social sur celui des lions ?
Oh, mais tu nous culpabilises !
Alors si je vous explique
comment on fait la purée,
on arrache les pommes de terre
du sol, on les épluche à vif,
on les coupe en morceaux,
les jette dans l’eau bouillante
et on les broie ensuite
pour finir en purée,
je suis à peu près sûre que, ce soir,
votre purée aura le même
goût que d’habitude.
Si ça nous touche autant les images,
par exemple, dans les abattoirs,
c’est parce que dans l’émotion,
dans les regards des animaux,
dans leur comportement,
on reconnaît des réactions
que nous-mêmes, on aurait pu avoir.
La peur, le stress, la fuite,
c’est ça qui nous parle.
Oh, et les carences ?
Ben oui, les carences ?
On est dans un monde aujourd’hui
où on souffre plutôt de nos excès,
de notre surconsommation
plutôt que de nos carences.
Excès de viande, c’est certains types
de cancer, cholestérolémie, par exemple.
Et au niveau des carences,
est-ce qu’en consommant 100 % végétal,
vraiment, on a des carences ?
Ce n’est pas ce que dit, par exemple,
l’Académie de nutrition et de diététique,
qui regroupe
cent mille professionnels de santé,
qui nous dit qu’on peut très bien
se nourrir végétarien ou végan
sans avoir aucune carence.
Albert Einstein,
lui-même végétarien,
nous dit qu’il est plus facile
de désintégrer un atome qu’un préjugé.
Alors, bref,
je n’aime pas les animaux,
mais je déteste les injustices,
et je suis sûre que c’est
la même chose pour vous.
Alors, agissons ! Agissons seuls,
agissons collectivement.
Agissons en baskets
en allant à la rencontre des gens
ou devant notre ordinateur.
C'est ça qui est important.
Rejoignez une association,
un collectif, par exemple.
Et puis,
je vous invite à sortir
du paradoxe de la viande par le haut,
en croquant la vie,
pas les animaux.
(Applaudissements)